elle se déhanche elle s'avance comme une
rose provocante elle est blonde elle est
à paris clin d'oeil avec christophe
martet et bernard giraudeau une foule et
conquérant quelques heures avant son
premier concert à bercy madonna cet aval
et 10 km d'asphalté parisien une
gymnastique quotidienne
si les six gardes du corps sur les
genoux à décor digne de metropolis pour
l'apparition d'une madone une walkyrie
que bonne soeur son show elle l'a
supervisé dans les moindres détails
obama
et c'est elle qui a choisi de revenir
aux ingrédients de ses premiers succès
une musique sucrée mais des textes qui
répète inlassablement que le sexe est
bien la meilleure façon de profiter de
notre passage sur terre ce qui fait de
madonna un personnage à part dans le
paysage de l'amérique puritaine que
jamais
ainsi nous nous sommes demandés
le loup provocant et sexy c'est en
france que madonna l'a trouvé grâce au
crayon de jean paul gaultier
ravi glavier elle est superbe avec
rebelles les mensurations parfaites
passé aviez très facile il est très très
facile si tout le monde était comme ça
serait très simple et la haute couture
peut-être vivre
et c'est aux côtés de voir une betty que
les amateurs pourront bientôt retrouver
madonna en vente façon années 30 dans
glee croatie déjà à méga succès aux
états unis
à 31 ans cet art caméléon a vendu 60
millions de 10,6 le titre de son dernier
album bref laisse peut se traduire par
abou dessous
madonna elle normand assurément pas pour
aller vite dans un instant